it is footage we've never seen before
of a siege that stunned america i want
you to pay attention to the first group
of assailants
as they break into the building you can
hear the terror in an officer's voice
here police body cameras capture them
wrestling with rioters
another angle shows mike pence and his
family ushered away from the chamber
the vice president turns around briefly
as he's headed down
a senator about to walk right into the
thick of it
is rushed back
these scenes prosecutors argue are the
product of a campaign by a president
who sold voters a lie and rejoiced
in the chaos it's a rigged election it's
the only way we're going to lose
but this will be one of the greatest
fraudulent most fraudulent elections
ever
he watched it on tv like a reality show
he reveled in it and he did nothing to
help us
as commander-in-chief instead he served
as the inciter
in chief sending tweets that only
further incited
the rampaging mob
democrats claim mr trump pushed these
people here
the defense argued he did nothing to
incite the violence
what the impeachment managers have tried
to do is force senators
to relive what happened on that day
inside this symbol of american democracy
and unlike the first impeachment trial
which often
seemed abstract this one feels like a
very
visceral reckoning for some
the emotions are easily triggered
i heard that terrifying banging on house
chamber doors
for the first time in more than 200
years
the seat of our government was ransacked
[Music]
here people try to hunt down the speaker
of the house
this trial is about whether donald trump
incited it
and we already know it's almost certain
he'll be acquitted
cordelia lynch sky news washington